[Música]
buenos días
y
literalmente
al otro lado del atlántico
esta huída me permitió darme cuenta de
muchas cosas
yo estudié una licenciatura en comercio
internacional
y pues después de haber trabajado en
compras en ventas haber estudiado sobre
tratados internacionales sobre derecho
aduanero pues me di cuenta que eso no
era lo mío y que en realidad soy una
ingeniera frustrada
porque porque les digo esto pues con
esta experiencia con esta vida tuve la
oportunidad de estudiar una maestría en
comercio electrónico ustedes me dirán
pues comercio internacional el comercio
electrónico pues como que es lo mismo no
pues si se parecen tienen que ver trata
de compraventa pero increíblemente la
maestría me permitió
adquirir nuevos conocimientos
conocimientos sobre la programación web
fue increíble cuando por primera vez
hice un sitio de web un sitio web de
venta en línea completamente desde cero
compra los productos es increíble
realmente todo lo que se pueda hacer con
programación
y pues bueno toda esta experiencia me
hizo reflexionar en un momento de mi
vida a los 18 años porque a esa edad yo
nunca pensé en estudiar una carrera
relacionada con informática o software
nunca nunca me pasó por la mente a pesar
de que era muy buena estudiante tenía
muy buenas calificaciones todas las
materias pero no nunca me pasó por ahí y
pues bueno desde hace cinco años he
venido reflexionando en esto y pues he
llegado a algunas conclusiones que les
quiero compartir el día de hoy la
primera es que no soy la única mujer que
no ha considerado las áreas de ciencia o
ingeniería como una opción para su vida
profesional
de acuerdo a estadísticas a un estudio
que hizo la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico en
2015 podemos ver el sesgo tan grande en
verdad tan grande que hay entre
intereses de chicas y chicos de 15 años
sólo 5% de las niñas que respondieron
este estudio mostraban interés por áreas
de ciencia y tecnología en comparación a
12 por ciento de los niños además los
niños tienen mayor interés en áreas de
informática o comunicaciones 5% de los
niños dijeron que les gustaban estas
áreas en comparación a solo punto 4% de
las niñas es increíble la diferencia no
además también este mismo estudio señala
que sólo 30% de los estudiantes de
carreras de ingeniería o ciencia eran
mujeres
por otra parte la unesco nos señala que
bueno ellos calculan que sólo el 28 por
ciento de los investigadores en el mundo
son mujeres
esto nos deja ver que los roles sociales
las pautas de conducta que nos inculcan
desde pequeños pues van encaminando a
las niñas a otras áreas totalmente
diferentes a la ciencia y la tecnología
ustedes no me dejarán mentir a los niños
les regalamos un carrito unos bloques de
construcción un robot mientras que
mientras que a las niñas les regalamos
pues una muñeca o un set de platitos
para jugar a la comidita
como educadores como padres como madres
sabemos que los juegos desde pequeños
pues van formando esa visión ese modelo
que los niños las niñas y los niños van
a tomar para su vida adulta
en segundo lugar las mujeres no tenemos
suficientes roles o modelos a seguir
si yo les preguntara ahorita que me
dijeran el nombre de alguna mujer que se
haya desempeñado en ciencia y tecnología
estoy prácticamente segura que la
mayoría me respondería solo marie curie
o a lo mejor ni me respondería nada
tranquilos no les va a ser un examen
simplemente los quiero invitar a que
reflexionemos el por qué el por qué no
podemos responder yo creo que no podemos
responder porque en tanto en casa como
en la escuela no hablamos de las pocas
mujeres que han hecho cosas increíbles
en ciencia y tecnología para las niñas
es muy importante tener modelos tener
roles a seguir saber que hay mujeres que
han recorrido este camino que las
mujeres también pueden experimentar
investigar desarrollar patentar si una
niña sabe que una mujer ya ha recorrido
ese camino pues ya no le va a tener
miedo va a saber se va a reflejar en
ella en esa mujer y va a tener mayor
seguridad
todo esto pues lo he visto en estos 5
años en los que afortunadamente he
podido coordinar actividades que
reflejan el gran trabajo de mujeres en
ciencia y tecnología a través de charlas
así como con talleres para niñas entre 4
y 11 años y en estas actividades pues me
he dado cuenta del gran poder que tiene
los roles los modelos a seguir para
inspirar a una niña en estas áreas
es increíble qué
al verse reflejadas
la capacidad de verse a sí mismas en
otra área les aparece en la mente
el año pasado iniciamos con un programa
que se llama aprendizaje creativo en
familia que básicamente consiste en
invitar a niñas a conjunto con sus mamás
y con sus papás también y pues durante
tres sesiones les enseñamos en qué
consiste la programación
y con esta actividad de reafirmado que
las niñas menores de nueve años
no tienen miedo a nada ellas hacen
deshacen y no tienen miedo a equivocarse
algo muy diferente en las niñas mayores
que sí muestran cierta inseguridad hasta
cierta renuencia hacia la tecnología
pero lo más sorprendente es que esa
misma renuencia y esa misma inseguridad
se ve reflejada en las mamas
está esta situación nos deja ver qué
si en casa no tenemos también estos
patrones pues muy difícilmente las niñas
lo van a poder hacer lamentablemente no
todas las niñas han completado nuestro
programa pero las que lo han hecho ha
sido gracias a que tienen una mamá muy
segura de sí misma o mamás que han
decidido dejar el miedo afuera y
aprender junto con sus hijas
además todo esto me hace pensar que pues
como sociedad que podríamos hacer para
que nuestras niñas tengan o crezcan con
un interés en ciencia y tecnología e
ingeniería también
yo creo que nuestro papel como adultos
es muy importante tenemos primero que
están nosotros convencidos de que las
niñas pueden hacer lo que sea lo que
ellas quieran
y que nosotros como adultos tenemos el
papel de inspirarles de motivar las
echarles porras de que ellas si pueden
lo podemos observar también en la
escuela hemos dado talleres a grupos de
quinto y sexto de primaria y es evidente
la diferencia que hay entre niñas y
niños los niños son más alentados e
inmediatamente tratan de resolver el
reto que les planteamos mientras que las
niñas pues
tienen como más miedito o esperan a que
un niño responda por ellos
les repito como adultos tenemos que
pensar que en algunos años los puestos
de trabajo que existen hoy en día van a
cambiar totalmente algunos hasta van a
desaparecer
y en ese momento pues nuestras niñas van
a tener que contar con habilidades
relacionadas a ciencia y tecnología para
poderse adaptar a todos estos cambios
para poder tener un buen empleo
así que los invito hoy a impulsar a
nuestras niñas para tener más mujeres en
ciencia y tecnología el día de mañana
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]